let's join the tournament arena Kings
join twenty seconds to spare
hello to people be Fox zero to Mason
hall o PBR alpi chess peppermint
biscuits
live fast oh maybe that means live fast
die young huh tallies back cat thumbs
able to catch a stream okay let's play
let's play a London just making sure my
layouts okay okay we're gonna have some
sort of ports they try and stay focused
and not look too much at the chat what's
the status of this tournament maybe
people can answer that not sure what
that means the tournament has just begun
two hours of three minutes yes thank you
seven yeah let's do let's do this it's a
pleasant opening I want to play h4 h5
and then eventually meet any fives
pretty typical for black I'm probably d5
hmm I could take him play f4 maybe let's
do that and later h4 h5 hmm could take
and play f4 again it's the advantage of
having double F pawns f4 strikes twice
Bishop h3 coming I'm expecting f6 f6
Bishop h3 it's the night Oh c5 so if I
take I can take this and then take here
also play
I'll take first
what to do I want a sack but maybe five
maybe try an IP five I'm just trying to
win a pawn wait I mop up on already
no I'm yeah I'm up upon pending this all
right let's put the bishop on a solid
square always flaking b1
in this move I'll sack the h-bomb Locke
wants to take it oh I missed a fork okay
that's not good
that's really not good
lights are tricky
and I lost a pawn okay at least I have
I'm gonna have a bishop on d5 that'll be
my main source of counter play can play
this right away
Queen belongs I think on d2 or even h6 I
have to watch out for tactics should
play a three soon hmm
let's do this let's do this g5 coming or
vertex g6 was a threat
maybe Queen g2 turning this something
nagging crusher also ideas of this okay
doc wants to meet me there's c4 c4 does
not feel safe
ooh okay this is this is good I'm
tacking up seven and pre-move taking it
hmm still tricky though this is very
tricky King belongs on a two queen g3
Queen here and then rook f3
oh no I'm just gonna meet it
oh no I miss Queen b3 King a2 is
terrible
well thanks for the sub and add two four
eight eight yeah I wrote eight seven
didn't quite work
the Queen was defended okay I'm playing
I forgot I had to pronounce his name and
- J is silent pre-series something he
beat me in over the board chess a few
years ago in Holland so time to get
revenge with a staffer gambit
what is this I do stuff and queen g4 is
a move
going after b2 and f2
it's a fork I'm Bishop III I take me to
and attack the rook mmm
I want to play this move takes
yeah it looks interesting not going
after b2 I'm just going for the tack why
did you play h5 to support Knight g4 now
I can take this pawn maybe Bishop d6 56
so Bishop e6 then there's rook b1 I
think this is okay rook the one Queen e5
Bishop g3 Queen g5 or it takes b7h for
Bishop takes c7 it gets messy h3 that's
just a big mess okay we go for none of
that maybe f6
our Bishop b6 let's play Bishop e6 safe
move ensuring I'm not losing v7 in some
lines so if work be one probably Queen
a3 or Queen c3 I still want to do this
in this and then this Bishop b6 also
defense e7 keeps upon safe d4 play off
six White has Center pawns I have seen
enough funds helping control the center
now g5 is actually a major threat play
Queen a3 Queen d3 and I taken g5h for oh
there's each three maybe I went up on
whoa exchange sac I take the bishop
first
I'll take your first and probably
queenside castling yeah the night no
longer belongs on g4 Bishop belongs on
g4 oh that's a good move I think I'm
losing pawns unless I want to sack the
exchange which maybe I do
hmm play h3 it's getting a little bit
tricky now Bishop here I should
eventually win d4
oh but there's still tricks was this hmm
I'll do this he's not taking my thing I
think I knew that this is a streamers
tournament but thanks for the sub
Firenze and Jay I don't know if I've
seen the specific player stream before
how long play 97 this is gonna get a
little bit messy place e5
you southern may be a six soon okay
let's get rid of this pawn let's take
this push my a pawn let's take this no
no I'm gonna lose again
no oh sad finish I was my second loss
both games have gone till the very end -
not a good start I got too comfortable
thought I was just gonna win on time
okay playing another strong player
someone beatable and said no meanie
thanks for uh thanks for subbing let's
get back on track now some idea of
taking if that plays a wrong move
okay I think I want a Castle queenside
still there's a few approaches to play
this position play positionally Castle
kingside
focus on center but if I Castle
queenside I can go for some attack what
does this move takes takes I went upon
maybe not let's take first Bishop g5
there's no each six cuz the battery
still want to do this I mean they p6 is
a move might be six maybe Bishop d3 okay
pawn c6 I think I'll play more
positionally let's start with start with
a four restricting b5 I'll probably end
up passing this way but I'm still
flexible and blocks taking a lot of time
I mean the traditional approach is this
and then this and then doing stuff
let's castle and I'd c5 expected
opponens just taking too long though
clay rookie one if 96 probably Bishop e3
there should be six in Queen e2 maybe
just gonna play solid improving moose
should be three now hitting the night
expecting Bishop takes see 496 Wow
unexpected should probably take this and
then Knight g5 still looks reasonable
takes takes up about minutes on the
clock first time viewing me live
rusty HS I've never been to Dublin the
only place in the UK that I've been to
is London would like to go to Dublin at
some points okay let's take and now what
could take again your rook d3 the D
files only open file so now there's some
battery FC 595 and then c3 will kick the
night yeah this is an outpost this is
not an outpost to play f3 now ooh that's
a fork I'm missing Forks today
thankfully it's not so bad I have a time
advantage
interesting hmm so a little bit weird in
Bishop c4 okay here we go
okay ah slightly messy finish but it's
my first win
okay let's try and use that as momentum
try and get a streak four Knights yeah
four Knights Scotch Knight takes e4 this
is a tricky tricky variation f3 is the
best move whoa wind bits momentum bits a
Bishop d7 I think is a move
Thanks soggy and lightning bolts for the
bits
what to do here I have a feeling
queenside castling is a move looks ugly
though my five is a move yeah I'm gonna
do this I aligned the rook with the
Queen have ideas of Queen c5 I have the
bishop hair there's some problem like
Bishop III this is gonna get really
weird Oh tog II said 100 bits for every
win well now I have to win the rest of
my games to make a living some Bishop d6
ideas - I mean this whole thing looks
really ugly but I'm not getting mated so
that's a plus the knight in some cases
is pinned in two directions and I'm up
on time
see three yeah that's solid some idea
Queen b6 to play c5 and then later
exploit the the Queen on d1 I might be
winning material and wherever the light
in the night moves I have Bishop c6
hitting the rook and the Queen I think
white should've played Bishop e3 sooner
alright Bishop c6 considering c5 I mean
White's gonna have some compensation in
Bishop e7 I'll just connect the rooks
our rook d3 looks interesting idea of
rook simply rook ht8 I wanna play rugby
one soon a c5 is probably a goner but
whenever white takes on c5 we can trade
stuff hey g3 can't be good weakening to
the light squares now I have some idea
of c4 when Queen is tied down to the
bishop so I'm looking for ways maybe g5
g5 is interesting there's also a 5x5 is
Oh F 5 he takes with check King B it's a
move hmm Bishop g5 also interesting oh
but then Queen f5 start with g5
expecting Queen at 5:00 or queen g4 and
then any Queen e6 just want to trade and
be happy oh you just bought some bits
how do you send them
well taggi has to respond tog ease of a
professional bit sender okay I have time
I have material what do I have
FC for wanna take doom thanks for
subbing rook is kind of stuck okay I did
it I think there's a there's a few
different ways to send bits actually you
can use a mouse you can also just type
cheer followed by a number the bigger
the number the better thinks Knight c8
thanks DJ DJ Allen on is back whoa a
case a KD 707 it's 2,000 bits some mega
cheer
thank you so much I guess you figured
that figured it out
congratulations yeah thank you everyone
nagi 98 okay let's use this as momentum
I have a two game win streak it's much
better than a two game Wall Street
what's your day job my day job is
playing chess and receiving bits and
also getting attacked what is this this
is really scary let's just play b3
thankfully it's not bug house mr.
million thanks for the bits bring the
knight back whoa Grandmaster gari and
howdy y'all I'm Billy it's like a bit
storm so many people it's turning into a
day job okay always play off three I'm
done a lot of time so I'm getting
distracted whoa it's Nicola whoa I lost
a bishop I lost a bishop oh no I just
got so distracted but I'm not gonna give
up hope I'm gonna attack I have founds
the bit storm is turning into a pawn
storm Queen c7 good move let's play h5
oh dear
what is this Queen d2 I don't want to
defend I want to attack
Queens III is coming play this move
it's a funny move if on Poisson I play
Knight c2 and I'm safe completely safe
at least for a mover to play this move I
want to take and meet whoa
this is like more bits than there was
rain yesterday in Malaysia
thanks so much tally I mean this this
game that I'm playing now I don't know
if it's like so bit worthy and this is
actually kind of terrifying so what do I
do
play e5 and opponents about to sack on
on b3 now this is so terrifying you look
here it's a slow move but I want to do
this and then eventually sack my queen
and meet this is not looking good it's
play Knight here to bring the knight in
somehow
yeah c2 can take this
two minutes to 20 seconds I'm down a
piece I'm about to get destroyed unless
I'm I'm surviving
maybe I'm surviving let's bring the rook
oh no I would get forked there I don't
see what to do let's play this move
anyway I'm about to get fort
I need tricks no I resign
okay you guys do not deserve that maybe
I deserved it
but let me you try and redeem myself
oh and and gory you're welcome for the
raid hope you had a good stream like one
hour without a loss very nice okay
redemption hopefully also the truth
thanks for who can I take this is
interesting line this line doesn't
happen so often there's a line after
King III castling and then King takes e4
and it's just ridiculous yeah I can't f3
I think it's very similar take my
Knights look at this double peace app
for the King in the center I have to
remember my lines though its Queen h4
King f3 and then Queen h5 take Queen e1
it's a new move I play Queen f6 Bishop
f4
and Queen f6 looks like the most natural
Bishop f4 e I could take I mean g5 is
begging to be played but probably not
right away to do I can't spend so much
time either
that's not g5
it's a problem because I have to have to
be the one creating ideas it's play
Bishop f5 it took a lot of time there I
just want to get the rook into play play
this move it's just about getting as
many pieces into play as possible I take
that take sticks
well it seems so close to working not
sure if that's gonna motivate me more
but I'm sorry for your issues oh let's
play 96 was my work trapped oh no my
crook actually trapped
I have counter-attack oh I have ripped
d1 - forgot about rook to d1 d1 I don't
want to trade Queens I think I have to
let's take and trade Queens Knight oh my
gosh I have 20 seconds - I really like
the opening in this game but now I
really don't like the position
it's to the smooth this is so sad
no okay okay more gambits will come more
gambits will come I'm gonna try and it's
try harder I'm playing stronger player
the truth some people give bits only
when I win but the truth give spits
regardless woo and ip5 this is nice trap
this is very nice trap I can resign
maybe just resign I need tournament
points I'm not even in the top 100 yeah
so many people I even strong players
fall into this but let's
okay let's convert this I mean I could
just take the exchange makes you sevens
a move unites c7 looks the most fun and
then like Bishop b5
even though g5o let's do this I want to
play this I just mess up by getting
trapped wait how does my night escape
takes takes oh no I should have just
taken the exchange I have this move
though it's still interesting you can
take this way yeah maybe it's not so bad
but it's not like as good as it could
have been Queen Dixie seven and here if
Queen here I have c3 ob5 I can I can't
take oh no I'm just losing material it's
turned around so quickly what is this
before interesting move before is
actually kind of interesting
this takes but see for good move
no this is so bad
okay I got too comfortable I was trying
to just finish things off in style and
now I'm down a piece okay I have I've
not lost a single pawn and it's about to
turn into bullet chess h3
that's four I guess it's still a fight
if my opponent can fight back from that
that opening position I can fight back
from this position some idea of queen h5
it's a strange phenomenon in chess when
you get like a really good or winning
position then you just start missing
your opponent's ideas or just blundering
so the whole concept of momentum shifts
I'm attacking the pawn won't play Queen
e2 in this or this so Brooke a two ideas
can take the pond wants to play Knight
yeah I'll play Queen e2 threatening both
this and this I like it
check yeah I might as well take ooh
forgot about that g4 its ambitious move
hmm oh no I'm losing more stuff g5 no I
mean lose this
do I even play on there's always a hope
of sale mates
oh what a sad finish a good opening I
fought back kind of oh I'm playing um I
think he beat me earlier actually beat
me earlier in the tournament also Chango
the legend thanks for thanks for the
bits this is a really disappointing
tournament so far yeah it happens play a
three
lomi pong thanks for subbing can't be
too greedy in life five is gonna come
what to do
my queen bee three if 'if I've maybe t5
some ninety six ideas not easy for a
block to stop 96 mmm yeah I'm scared of
this movin the bishop becoming strong so
I might just trade off whoa
okay now the opponents being greedy I
mean that might just be like a really
good move I mean what do I have here
Queen c2
I'm a g3 g3 so so sad but I'll do it
defends f2 at the taxa Queen
tree Momsen AC ok this position is now
just a mess you can take this and if
Knight takes h2 our Castle queenside
[Music]
and 95 coming hmm I can bring the other
night to e6 maybe but the night here for
now
[Music]
I have a bad feeling about this
kki Elroy thanks for subbing I have a
very bad feeling about this takes takes
maybe I'll take twice I have this move
mmm probably not good
[Music]
I'm just moving too slowly okay so my
dear okay wanted to take stuff might be
slow but at least it's a plan that's a
very good move okay I'm just going for
the breakthrough now pawns are fixed
running rookie seven oh dear okay only
hope is stalemate at this point
[Music]
no let's just resign let's move on so
hopefully better things lost a lot of
reading I think I've lost like 50 points
this tournament
okay gambit time
Stafford gambits declines
[Music]
ninety-two play this turning this
[Music]
Argentina in the chat thanks for the
comments play f5 very stone wall like
Queen b3 is typical after Queen b3 I
might lose a pawn
okay now the pawns defended I want to
play c6 ooh
and Bishop e5 I go to play knight c6
but I'm gonna artificial castle and this
should be reasonable on some idea Queen
b6 to Knight g5 ooh
tricky oh this is very tricky I have
King g6 oh this is gonna be a mess
g4 coming what's going on maybe it's not
so bad g4 and I takes g5 takes in the
king f7 I don't want a pre move King f6
by each six here oh I'm not getting
needed yet
oh but I am losing a bishop by dropping
a knight this is just such a mess such a
mess I'm at one time a little bit tilted
not sure if it's like tilter it's just
sleepiness or lack of focus f3 let's
keep the file closed behind this move
Knight g3 is a fork but III looks more
attractive it's actually looks very
attractive because a bishop is shut out
which means the rook is shut out when
weights pieces aren't really
coordinating like I play this
threatening made in one or that that
looks strong play Bishop f4 this looks
very questionable but I'm holding on to
e3 this is my invincible pawn
I think the invincible pawn is stronger
than a fork Knight okay no more Knight
up a lot of time the Queen takes d4
Oh Queen f7 I mean I have to just deal
with it
I mean a7 Queen f6 if I'm not getting me
that maybe all I'll survive
yeah this is what I was hoping for
because now okay the pawn is still
invincible I have this check and then
this should be - will come with check
this move hey thanks so much
Africa 15 months Queen f7 meets I had
kini five play to play I can't keep the
tension let's play R up to you
threatening rookie - lets this move work
this works
or he cookie one but I'll I'll get the
rook to c2
it should've been a pawn mmm let's take
this just have to keep my rook the
bishop is almost trapped
[Music]
okay I want a game it takes so much work
to win you're doing better than the
Cardinals are doing that gives me hope
does give me hope there's always a
perspective like that I'm staying above
2600 to play e6 this game
hey it's bits okay I haven't won in so
long I forgot about the win bits let's
play uh an Enzo play b6 like c8 thanks
for the bits I posted a video on youtube
today
showing showing the slang I'm showing
this line pawn takes pawn
I forgot what to play here
oh yeah Bishop takes and then takes well
this is supposed to be pleasant for luck
this Bishop stuck all Castle they go for
c5 at some points or not
a c6 light belongs on d6 not sure how I
get it there
[Music]
maybe rookie six this light will come
here and this light will come here on d6
it controls efore and c4 these are two
nice squares that could be a good move
so I'll bring this Knights defending
defending the pawn king ghidorah says
nice to see you alive
finally at first I read that as nice to
see you live it's nice to live let's
gather a triple battery going I'm not
sure if that's good though because might
be five I'll bring the knight here Wow
tactics does that work it probably works
that's unfortunate
that's really unfortunate Knights there
doesn't do anything think I have to take
[Music]
yeah I'm down upon
that's really sad let's avoid the rope
trade and t5 is gonna come still have to
be optimistic it's hard to be optimistic
when the position is so so awful
maybe ideas of this this and this I
always have to watch out for g7e for a
tricky move like Queen g4 expecting a
5v5 not a5 and at least I have a threat
[Music]
maybe g5 someday because what else
that's a very strong move I'm just
losing left and right I resign yeah I
was really really sad when did you start
on Twitch almost exactly two years ago
at least streaming consistently I think
I made my channel cops three years ago
but in terms of streaming about two
years ago okay tilted enraged I'm not
going to lose hope let's play h4
I mean at this point it's just about
playing aggressively yeah so I've
succeeded in gambling upon not sure if
that's actual success but now the goal
is to use my my extra open file
maybe rook b5 at some points okay let's
take this first
yeah it's just about hyperaggression ooh
okay this looks fun
start with rook b3 Bishop e3
start with Bishop e3 Queen c3 King f1
now will not bring the light to d4 I'm
hitting this light then hitting or
threatening the fork lights 96 will be
quite nice okay this is what I need
good move
Oh what to do Black's getting comp play
Brooks III the night is super solid but
everything's defended they work h3 and
run with the king maybe III just trying
to hold my ground hey Black Sabbath is
actually quite nice it might take 64
I'll pre move this I think I'm just
winging a piece yeah okay
that ended kind of abruptly back on
track there's okay
halfway through the tournament's it's
honestly felt like several hours so far
a half way through let's make a strong
second half and let's attack attack
chest kid boom
okay this is what I need another opening
trap I mean every game for the rest of
the stream will be aggression and trying
to win quickly and gambits probably like
the smooth nights eh Thank You aunt
Aggie and DJ all right let's put the
Queenie here I want to play Bishop g4
I'll start with f6
always play off six Bishop g4 almost
rocks our queen some Bishop t2 ideas
[Music]
was there a loud noise apologies if
there's a loud noise
your your ears just hurting play off 5i5
looks interesting your castle what you
do for a living yeah
I mean earlier I half jokingly said I
just play chess and receive bits but I I
don't have like a traditional job I have
probably like five or six different
different sort of side jobs different
gigs does this move white wants to just
promote the pawn
okay let's attack the Queen
so like streaming and YouTube contents
it's more of just passion for me but it
is in some way considered a job but also
private coaching doing doing like event
reports I'll be I'll actually be helping
out for the the next grand chess to her
event
she takes place in India but I'll be
working from st. Louis I'm also also an
adjunct professor at Webster University
teaching a few chest courses this
semester I take this pawn can take this
pawn okay this is gonna end very badly I
[Music]
just have to watch out for b7 okay I'll
play b6 first
[Music]
yeah other minutes push upon d2 just
enjoying life sometimes you have Queen
III okay I'm threatening me than to now
yeah I do live in st. Louis I'm based in
San Luis currently in Malaysia trying to
enjoy life just like this Bishop on a
small vacation free queen okay next game
ooh playing strong player let's play
English I fell below 2600 you have to
get back up again this is a line hey
let's move taki thank you yes III hear
DJ thank you yes I don't mind the
structure actually kind of like it just
keep applying pressure keep developing
I'll play h5 and the far distant future
maybe h5 and IG 6 ideas never minds play
C 5 and B 5 interesting
[Music]
ooh think I'll take that it's a closed
position lights should be preferable
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah it's gonna be a lot of maneuvering
have to be a little bit careful here
[Music]
after you very careful ooh
that's not quite what I wanted that King
belongs on a one now or a three maybe
King a three this looks looks very ugly
unbox battery was strong yeah I'll I'll
try and answer questions later it's hard
to answer questions and play in this
tournament I take the pawn I think I can
take the pawn there's a pin I can take
the Bishop Knight here is stronger
and control c4 so I want to play Queen
c2 just get rid of that Queen but I
don't consider myself a chess or like a
professional chess player more of like
educator g3 is annoying
let's take half still dues upon I have
some activity now her icky eighths is a
threat at Bishop g4 not sure if the
Queen trade is good for me
it's interesting though let's play this
move oh no I'm losing this fun
hmm it's my dear Queen g2 oh no I'm just
getting mated oh I forgot about Queen b3
no I liked my position too
especially after Knight takes e4 okay
blue the pest time alpha Bush says just
one over the board tournament this
weekend wanted to say thanks learning
from last year I'm great to hear
congratulations
keep it up even when you win you should
always go back analyze your games try
and take away a few lessons from your
games to do here and go for a rock a6
and g3 is solid
[Music]
you're up t6 I guess looks very strange
but I couldn't resist the rook lifts
I wanna play 94 this is so strange ever
work on d6 that's somehow so now I'm
winning the bishop hair hey enough 6
runs in to be 5 I guess I'll take and
then d6 what is this a far far far far
one thanks for something hey you five is
kind of scary could maybe take on a four
and Bishop c5 check
it's Queen a8 kind of defends everything
[Music]
and this is still kind of terrifying
well I'm alive I'm so passive maybe see
six will come now Queen da loses upon
your work to you
[Music]
okay with Bishop g4 it means I'm playing
for a win avoiding the Queen trade
avoiding the ops of Clark Bishop draw so
I like the bishop here and then I'll go
for this yeah I definitely have chances
these end games are very deceiving
sometimes because sometimes they look
Josh but with Queens on the board it can
be very tricky I'll start with b6
ooh okay let's go back from where I came
from down a little bit of time
interesting move
[Music]
yeah this is hope
okay White's playing for a win now okay
so we're both playing for a win in this
move
oh no that losses play this move no wait
what
okay that was a slightly sad now slip
this is not good
[Music]
somehow there's still a little bit of
hope
[Music]
oh okay
somehow I won that was nasty it's really
nasty sorry people had to witness such
nastiness a far far far thanks so much
1000 bits I don't know if I deserve any
bits for that but I guess I was that was
a win
it wasn't Bishop to e3
I should t3 is very strange
it's a bit storm ok let's take a pause
why nots
and Queen h4 if Queen f3 and then lady
h2 is a fork a far far far with a
thousand more bits oh my gosh maybe I do
deserve it for being me o Queen e2 is
played let's not get too distracted
it's just developed whoa oh that was the
same bits but thanks so much anyways
okay I like my position before that's a
good sign I stay focused keep up the
pace probably want to just play
improving move soon I don't want to
blunder a piece so I'll play this move
okay
I play the gambit and now I'm up upon
what to do Bishop here
whoa what does this move let's play this
move I think this is all looking like a
very nice attack well a far far far far
so many more bits can I take this well
it's close to working but not quite oh
it's so close well I have this move
though oh but then takes hmm let's just
play Bishop d5 okay thanks so much a far
far far far I have to stay focused maybe
be five B five other rook deserves a
life let's play this move and then
yes I can take ok defending stuff okay
Bishop c4 could be interesting this is
becoming tricky
[Music]
let's take with uh oh wow like Queens
hanging oh no just losing material
losing material okay this is not good
and I'm down a ton of time a far far far
far aside has been watching on YouTube
for a while nice sadly things are not
going so well here tell you this move
it's maybe six first
[Music]
okay let's push pawns
maybe g5 coming I'm on a fork
Bishop i5 expected I just want to win
this pawn and infiltrates
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
sad very sad opponent had a nice tactic
somewhere there it's lady five this game
[Music]
the competition doesn't get easier they
I keep losing but I keep playing strong
players that's part of life maybe six
maybe six
[Music]
what's going on here my losing material
I'm losing material okay not gonna give
a hope I'll treat this like a gambits
I'm playing the tournament leader oh wow
feel like I don't deserve to be in the
situation let's try and take him down
and despite the terrible opening maybe
this move okay I have to avoid trades a
far far far far but thanks so much
that's so many 1000 bits yeah I need the
femoral and um yeah just some moral
support situations like this I do have a
time advantage
that's one pro g6 make any sense
let's put the bishop here whoa gosh
thanks so much guys not sure if any
amount of support can see in this
position though but I'll try but how do
I try I guess I'll take and then take
here cut down the exchange have one
single pawn for it I'll put the work on
b4 and then the Queen on b5
[Music]
opponents playing strongly though what
to do takes I guess maybe I should just
abandon the queenside
and focus on the kingside I have three
minor pieces they have to attack that's
my one hope to h5 I have a pawn - yeah
all avoids pieces are on the Queen side
except for the king that's usually a
good sign but I'm down material and
things are about to get traded play this
move
[Music]
Oh No can I avoid the trade have to
trade Queens that's a good question
I do viewer challenge streams on me
chests I try and do them once a week
this month it's difficult because I'm
traveling a lot but when I'm back in st.
Louis I'll be back at the end of the
month oh I'll have more Sun playing sub
people streams I just resigned this
I don't like resigning though when I
have two nights those nights can be so
tricky
okay a lot of maintenance tile
ouch oh man
half hour left this turn is going by so
slowly but let's play aggressively yeah
I usually play subs when I have access
to the extension and you'll each us you
can connect your twitch name your Li
chest name and then it detects if you're
a sob and then you'll be more likely to
get a game 96 let's play Bishop e2 okay
I want a Marazzi Bynes
this is still theory this is uh this has
been played number of times like top
level GN play Caruana has had this
position think a few times play nine a
four it looks weird but it's interesting
the listen this o DJ Allen on will be in
st. Louis over Xmas I don't know if I'll
be in st. Louis during that time so I
might be in Europe but if I'm around or
if you're around shoot me a message
let's take this yeah I'm not really
getting much here we're just gonna trade
and we'll have some some sort of
position so I think ding will seriously
challenge Magnus I mean he proved
himself at Sinquefield Cup so I guess
time will tell
this is not a comfortable position I'm
going to be losing I'm only down pawn
after Queen Dixie 4 but my king is
complete trash ok but let's just try and
recuperate
oh there's Queen g2 oh this is not
pleasant
Oh Bishop C - Wow my opponent has a draw
if he wants it
but good decision not taking it what do
I do here
rook d2 is coming this is such a bad
position my pieces I are just completely
terrible um
Queen no Knight c3 92 maybe a let's try
this and Knight deserves a better life
and by better life it's gonna get like
pinned and attacked so many times on e 2
yeah this is going to be brutal if these
if there's any young children watching
close your eyes
actually everyone watching just close
your eyes pretend that nothing bad is
happening if I take this no okay
safety oh that's a threat oh it's a very
strong move now there is no stopping
Queen D it's Oh No
I hope you guys are still closing your
eyes okay now you can reopen them oh man
this is rough life is rough
I didn't flag I did not fight oggi a far
far far far trying to cheer me up
it's playing a g5 no patience for whoa
what is this ship t2
this is a tax can take on let's take on
at 7:00 with this nights maybe before
coming in G for is a move not in good
shape to play chess this is interesting
position still try and work through it f
f3 f3 a move always playoff 3 soso teeth
or III Bishop to e3 ideas
let's just play g4 kind of random I want
to play e4 and just attack the Queen
just a completely messed up position I
[Music]
don't think I'm getting needed
and queen is almost trapped I think this
is only square for it I have 95 maybe h4
I wanna play h5 maybe but then there's
my takes h5 53 95 95 Knight takes e5
play f4 I kind of forgot about that I be
5 mm
okay I'm only losing a piece it's not
the end of the world I I have pawns
this is actually really weird
cuz where does this light move he ate
five knight g6 king of seven 9h8 this is
very strange
a far far far far thousand more bits
thanks so much
wait I'm winning a piece of town as mine
a chase if it saves me it's not so bad
now I can take
oh my Knights gonna be trapped though
but the Black Knight is also trapped
this is so weird
I don't know what to do or maybe I'll
just take an R or H 7 now let's bring
the knight back and go for a 5
okay it's equal material somehow the
rook control the file prevent black from
castling even though I think the king
has moved already oh maybe this move I'm
done a lot of time hmm no no there goes
my bishop I had such a beautiful
position too
[Music]
this is so sad
just trying to sneak in from behind
I was not sneaky enough not sneaky you
know this is probably like my worst
Serena Kings at her
maybe this will go on YouTube people can
tear me apart in the YouTube comments
focus
just because focus is in all caps I'll
try and focus focus write me out my
opponent has walked into a trap
this is very nice trap I play them on
the last during the Kings I played he
fell into another staff a gambit Chuck
John Davis thinking of cruel comments as
I speak only wait no this is completely
winning for black a six moves it's
already resigned
but I've had so many games let's turn me
where I've had good positions and I
messed up my mic fell off stand there we
go okay let's take the take the pawn 18
minutes left to show what I'm made of I
have to still attacked it's hard to
defend Queen f3 take with the bishop or
take with the Knights how does this work
if I take with Bishop I need follow-up
I'll take with Knight
look safer also then Bishop g4 is some
idea okay white wants to meet me let's
castle and Bishop g4 coming soon
wait which game should I focus on this
game or next game while castle here that
would be hilarious but also be will okay
Bishop g4 if Queen afore I have amazing
move Bishop e3 threatening mates I
should III look at this Bishop e3 does
that work
I think that works what a beauty
someone clip this oh no it doesn't work
don't clip it I thought it was mate it's
not mates I just lost a piece for
nothing no also yes thanks for the bits
what no I didn't even drag the Queen
what is this are you serious it's Queen
g3 I thought I turned off click click is
click like on click how is click click
on I swear I turned off click click okay
I'm gonna fight back because my pone
slightly long time it's only Queen ants
and also night odds also I'm getting
needed unless I can run I'm gonna run
and hide the best of both worlds okay
King g7
plate b6 get some punching action hmm
yeah White's gonna sack I'll just run to
a 6 ok the trick is not to get mated and
then to dirty flag the prospects do not
look good I mean what do I do
let's play rope chief for attack stuff
how he wants to Mimi mm-hmm
[Music]
have to try this there's no hope here
[Music]
unless there is hope
no there's no hope oh I was winning
after six moves as black and then I I'm
Mouse I first I played Bishop III which
didn't work and then I mouse slipped
queen d3 and you did you guys really
clip that okay let's play the UM the
hillbilly this is a fun opening
[Music]
I met our talk in at the PCL finals very
nice person but no mercy this game yeah
this is actually called the hillbilly
right it even says it hillbilly this
Schaefer gambit that's interesting move
what do I do
it's a thousand more bits
the sympathy bits okay let's take I
think there's a game actually on Carlsen
thomashefsky that had some position like
this not sure whether to play d3 let's
play nine three first
I was like the world blitz championship
Carlson was just down upon but then just
one somehow I don't want to give up the
bishop hair okay then go for D for
actually getting some comp as the pawns
attacks of Bishop f4 Bishop f3 and
bishops are doing work
Bradon than in the chats Braden if
you're just joining this is probably my
worst arena Kings ever I've been losing
game after a game after a game but apart
from that I'm doing well how are you
doing I take I'm gonna take the pawn
that doesn't work
take the night let's do this
oh there's gonna be Bishop Bishop c5
coming try and make the most of it
Bishop c5 c3 hamster cam thanks for
subbing I wonder hamster cam are you
also a streamer I'd imagine you stream
just a hamster like I'd be a cool stream
just a 24/7 hamster cam okay let's play
a four I'll play a five rook d1 Bishop
e2 and then b4 mates okay nevermind oh
you've been watching for a year now
nice well thanks for the sub so I'm
still down the pawn but I'm not down on
hope also up a lot of time
my books are coordinated and rookie 2 is
gonna happen promise rookie 3 let's all
play this move
[Music]
interesting to play be three maybe three
if rookie three be for I'm down upon but
time is more relevance
[Music]
actually close to meeting but not quite
okay
oh the Cardinals are down six zero okay
playing George easy crew jeez it was
this name Pooh geezers Reser's Roland
okay I can't pronounce names but I can
plague and it's 1,000 bits and 100 bits
ok I'm going for the same same sort of
stuff thanks so much people oh those are
the wind bits that I rarely receive I've
lost way more games at stream than I've
won this move of Queen g3 here win g3
almost works also weightless move just
wins a queen nice ok can I take on h3 I
kind of want to take on h3 but I know
it's wrong let's not take on h3 let's
win this and in smoother fashion
[Music]
what's the material I've a queen for two
minors but the bishop on b7 I'll Castle
queenside and enjoy life always playoff
six actually never playoff six never
mind
always playoff six in g5 ooh
95 coming wait this is kind of scary
this is becoming competitive terms of
bits also in terms of this position what
is this rook he's sacking on a thing
this can't be good
[Music]
wait what's material I have a queen and
a rook for three miners it should be
more than enough put the King here
this could be my last game actually have
to make the most of it
whoa far far far far I just try playing
an illegal move let's just take the
thing rook here and c4 explosive I want
to play g4 g3 I also want to open the D
file
Oh what to do on b5 say a queen for two
bishops it's a little bit tricky now G
pawn is doing work also ideas of this
and this just have to sneak in
oh there's a nice idea g3 and then rook
h1 this rook h1 work no it doesn't work
cuz Bishop g1 ok let's play this move it
almost worked though okay this is
getting a little bit uncomfortable
I better not lose this I was winning
after like seven moves Bishop g4 King d8
let's take this Oh No
okay 20 may than one not sure how block
stops it I guess that's how still
threatening me than one this is me okay
I won the game it's a miracle
there won't be any time to finish this
game but I'll try and win quickly oh my
gosh a far far far far is not stopping
thanks so much just going for the attack
and the wind bits for next yeat DJ
Kingston miracle Pitts okay let's take
this
yeah there's two minutes and some change
in the tournament so my only hope is to
have my opponent plunder made in one I
want to go for Bishop h6 while I go for
Knight g5 and just a quick meeting
attack
if the opponent wants to you could just
stall and let the tournament and it
might be what's happening or maybe not
okay
going through the still feels like a
hillbilly attack
[Music]
Oh am I getting needed let's go this way
please play Knight g4 it attacks the
Queen and threatens meat oh we maybe are
going to draw this I don't want to draw
though I can play this move Oh Bell is
out losing I might be losing okay I'll
take a draw yeah okay why they wanted
tournament
Benjamin downs asking if you put this on
YouTube go through the last game and
rewind to threatening rook each one you
know there you got it yeah uh yeah so I
can explain why that doesn't work
whoa it got smaller
it turns over a wonderful time
congratulations fruga and Itsuki
I placed I don't even want to look at
what I place I think I placed in the top
hopefully the top 150 127 okay
well I'll show this let me show this
real quick going back there going
forward yeah it looks like it looks like
it's meaning but if I do this takes here
here here this does not meet because of
Bishop g1 and then white should be
winning this so as good I I saw this and
I I did not self-destruct but yeah I
think I'll put this on youtube
two hours of tragedy and trauma YouTube
people you can voice your sympathy and
the chat you can also just tear me apart
in the chat or have an F in the chat and
hopefully there will be better things to
come